yesterday you took part in a panel
discussion here at the fdth council
event on do we really need fiber before
you give me your points tell me a little
bit about ekta the organization that you
represent
actor is the european competitive
telecommunications association brian
and
we represent the challenger operators of
europe so really the challengers to the
former monopolist incumbent operators
who typically provide competitive and
innovative broadband and triple play
services
they are also
the so-called mobile entrance
and thirdly
business service providers often you're
often offering services to pan-european
multinationals for example okay so what
were your you know what was your input
to the session today
i think it is very important to bear in
mind that competition is really the best
way for europe to explore its digital
future and therefore i think the path
towards that digital future
will actually really define the outcome
so i think from this perspective it is
extremely important that regulation that
policy actually supports in focuses on
enabling competition and enabling
competitors to invest efficiently in
their own networks
and to compete and to innovate
yes i would imagine that your membership
therefore are very very much in favor of
this concept of building open networks
indeed
of course challenger operators
tend to provide
access to others when they build their
own networks but equally
when you think about fixed broadband
networks you should think about them as
being very similar to for example
electricity lines or water pipes or or
gas pipes so that you can never really
create
effectively competition by expecting
that there will be you know four or five
of those lines going to
into one single home so therefore
actually having access to those very
last miles of the fixed broadband
network
is the best and proven way to actually
create competition
to create affordable prices for end
users
and and innovative products
and and therefore of course i think it's
very important that regulation going
forward
refocuses on making sure that the
broadband markets when it comes to very
high speeds often supported by fiber
are competitive
and they really deliver affordability
innovation to the end user yes now of
course there's going to be a telecoms
review coming up by the eu so what would
you like to them to see
like you to see them do
um i think that a key challenge and i
would argue that a key task of the
revision of the eu's telecoms framework
is really to make sure
that in in the next generation of
broadband
the market will remain effectively
competitive or rather it will become
effectively competitive uh there is a
very high risk and we see developments
in this regard today
that europe would slide back on
competition indeed in some of the
high-speed broadband markets
the incumbent operators are really
regaining market shares so you can see
up to 70 percent retail market share
that is very worrying and that should be
a worrying sign so i think it is of
utmost importance that when it comes to
next generation broadband networks
regulation focuses on creating
competition not letting europe slide
back and also that regulation with the
so-called physical access products like
unbundling in sub loop unbundling
actually ensures that
alternative competitive operators can
invest in their own networks and compete
effectively
with the former monopolies or other
networks
thank you very much for talking to us
thank you brian
so a call there from actor for more and
more competition in the marketplace